Ya hemos hablado sobre varios tipos de sólidos.
Hemos hablado de sólidos iónicos que se forman
cuando tenemos iones que se atraen entre sí y
forman estas estructuras reticulares. Hablamos
de sólidos metálicos y los vimos como iones
positivos en un mar de electrones cargados
negativamente. Y también hemos visto sólidos
moleculares que se forman a partir de moléculas
individuales que se atraen entre sí por fuerzas
intermoleculares. Ahora, la diferencia con los
sólidos de red covalente es que éstos son redes
enteras formadas por enlaces covalentes. Lo que
vemos aquí, por ejemplo, es carburo de silicio,
una red de silicio y carbonos. Algunos de ustedes
podrían pensar "¿No hemos visto antes enlaces
covalentes involucrados en un sólido, por ejemplo,
en sólidos moleculares?" Y este de aquí es un
ejemplo de sólido molecular que estudiamos en
ese video. Tenemos las moléculas que están
formadas por átomos unidos con enlaces covalentes,
pero la razón por la que forman un sólido es
porque las moléculas se atraen entre sí por medio
de fuerzas intermoleculares. Y si quisiéramos
fundir este sólido molecular tendríamos que
superar estas fuerzas intermoleculares.
Entonces en un sólido de red covalente,
el sólido en gran medida está formado por estos
enlaces covalentes, y si quisiéramos fundir esto
de alguna manera tendríamos que superar estos
enlaces covalentes que, en general, son más
fuertes que estas fuerzas intermoleculares.
Así que pueden imaginar que los sólidos de
red covalente tendrán puntos de fusión más altos.
Tampoco vemos un mar de electrones aquí, entonces,
a diferencia de los sólidos metálicos, los
sólidos de red covalente no serán buenos
conductores de electricidad. Pero sólo para
entender este punto un poco más claramente,
echemos un vistazo a algunos sólidos de
red covalente. Pueden reconocer que aquí
a la izquierda tenemos un diamante. Un
diamante es un montón de carbonos unidos
entre sí por enlaces covalentes y esta es la
estructura de cómo están unidos estos carbonos,
y como ya sabrán el diamante es el sólido más
duro que conocemos. Estos enlaces covalentes,
por la forma en que están estructurados, pueden
requerir mucho estrés, muchos empujones y tirones;
es muy difícil romperlo. Ahora, lo interesante es
que el mismo carbono puede formar diferentes tipos
de sólidos de red covalente. Por ejemplo, esto
de aquí es grafito, y el grafito es algo con lo
que probablemente estamos bastante familiarizados:
cuando escribimos con un lápiz básicamente estamos
raspando grafito en un pedazo de papel. Y es
así como se ve el grafito, como láminas de redes
covalentes, y estas láminas se atraen entre sí
mediante fuerzas intermoleculares, y es por eso
que es fácil rasparlo, ya que estas hojas pueden
deslizarse entre sí. Pero si realmente quisiéramos
fundir grafito tendríamos que romper estos enlaces
covalentes. Y podemos imaginar que para superar
los enlaces covalentes y fundir el diamante o el
grafito se necesita una temperatura muy, muy alta.
El grafito, por ejemplo, se sublima a 3,642°C, el
carburo de silicio que vimos al principio de este
video se descompone a 2,830°C. Esto de aquí es una
imagen de cuarzo, que es una forma muy común de
dióxido de silicio, otro sólido de red covalente,
y tiene un punto de fusión de 1,722°C. Entonces,
la gran conclusión sobre los últimos videos es que
hay muchas maneras diferentes de formar un sólido:
puede ser con iones, puede ser con metales,
puede ser con moléculas que se atraen entre sí,
con fuerzas intermoleculares o puede ser una
red de átomos formados con enlaces covalentes.